the prime minister's plans include a new
unit to monitor small boats to try to
prevent the fragmented approach of
previous attempts to tackle Channel
Crossings
using sites such as disused holiday
parks and former military Barracks to
house up to ten thousand Asylum Seekers
waiting for decisions
an agreement with Albania including fast
tracking removal of most Albanian
migrants and placing UK border Force
officials in Tirana Airport
restarting flights taking migrants to
Rwanda for processing as soon as legal
challenges are over and legislation next
year to stop anyone who enters the UK
illegally from settling here our
political correspondent Joe Pike reports
another prime minister hi I'm Rishi
another raft of promises on immigration
because it is a massive priority for the
country to tackle small boats today
Rishi sunak toured the headquarters of
the National Crime agency to mark one of
the first major moves of his Premiership
enough is enough
and whilst as with the economy and
public sector pay he framed his new
policies in terms of fairness it is
unfair that people come here illegally
it is unfair on those who migrate here
legally when others come here by
cheating the system the PM is also
trying to look tough we are the only
party Mr Speaker that has a plan to
tackle these issues a new small boats
operational command in the channel deals
with Albania and France cheaper
accommodation tougher immigration
enforcement and new legislation making
it clear in law for the first time that
if you come here illegally you cannot
stay the comparatively empty labor
benches suggest this is not a priority
for kierstama's party even if he
realizes it is a political danger the
unworkable gimmicks go on so do the
crossings we need to bring this to an
end that means a proper plan to crack
down on the gangs quick processing
return agreement serious solutions to a
serious problem and that is what labor
will offer
more than 40 000 migrants have crossed
the channel this year a new record the
backlog of claims is now north of 143
000 and that's after 12 years of
conservatives claiming they want change
immigration has been too high you can
only trust the conservatives on
immigration we simply cannot have a
policy of saying anyone who wants to
live here can do so strengthening our
borders and beefing up our border force
in Parliament those representing seats
close to the channel seem cautiously
relieved they're a first step towards
solving the many problems in the Asylum
system I particularly welcome the deal
with Albania which has obviously been a
particular problem with the small boats
across the channel and I also welcome
moves to take Asylum Seekers out of town
center hotels including in in my
constituency in Ashford whilst red wall
MPS believe their jobs depend on
backlogs being cleared and hotels empty
seat the devil's in the detail and the
delivery has to follow because if it
doesn't the conservative party will be
out of the next election we've been
promising the past two or three years to
control our borders especially after
brexit if we don't control them and we
don't start sending people back and we
don't see a reduction in the numbers and
we don't see the hotels trade up and
then we've got big problems
you mean you're going to lose the next
election more than likely yeah
but in the marginal seat of crew some
sympathy for Asylum Seekers they're
trying to get over here for a better
life and we should be doing our best to
give them that we can if somebody's come
from a war-torn environment that's
unsafe or they're being persecuted then
you can't just send them back straight
away that's immoral there are so many
immigrants that are not supposed to obey
that rules there must be they must
follow these rules number 10 has now
clarified Rishi sunac is only committed
to clearing about two-thirds of the
current backlog by the end of next year
and while some critics of today called
these policies cruel ineffective and
unlawful some right-wing Tory MPS
including Boris Johnson won the prime
minister to go further with a new law to
allow the government to ignore the
European Court of human rights which has
helped block deportation flights to
Rwanda
today Rishi sunak has succeeded in
giving himself time and space but if he
fails to deliver results he'll likely
get a frosty reception on his back
benches and at The Ballot Box Joe Pike
Sky News Westminster